I am the son of a black woman who still
worries about my safety from the bias of
privilege and violence that accompanies
it I am a man who understands the pain
of unjustified profiling and I am the
first District Attorney of color not
only in Dane County but in the state of
Wisconsin I conclude at this tragic and
unfortunate death or the results of a
lawful use of deadly police force and
that no charges should be brought
against officer Kinney in the death of
Tony Robinson Jr
recent violence around our nation is
giving some in our communities a
justification for fear hatred and
violence Reverend dr. Martin Luther King
jr. said violence brings only temporary
change violence by creating many more
social problems than it solves never
brings permanent peace
you